with those words Sudan's military junta
came to an end and a transitional
sovereign council took its place
the council has five members from the
coalition known as the forces of freedom
and change and five from the military an
eleventh member agreed upon by both
sides makes up the body that will lead
Sudan's three-year transitional period
on the streets people reacted everyone
is happy and satisfied but if anything
happens and if we did not see anything
new from the revolution being achieved
we will surely hold another revolution
and topple the council same as we did
with Omar al-bashir all the members of
the sovereign council are accepted by us
the formation of the sovereign council
comes after a power-sharing agreement
was signed between the coalition and the
military on Saturday after months of
protests it had been a point of
contention between the two sides with
disagreements over its role and who will
have a bigger say now the council will
be led by the military for the first 21
months of the transitional period and by
a civilian from the forces of freedom
and change Coalition for the remaining
18 months it will have the role of
overseeing the Executive Council and
Legislative Assembly in which the
opposition will have a majority
representation the forces of freedom and
change has been representing the protest
movement and the talks to form a
transitional government and all its
institutions now people on the streets
say they'll be keeping an eye on that
coalition and the institutions including
an independent judiciary to make sure
that their demands for justice and
accountability and better living
conditions are met the weight now is for
the next steps in the journey to a
democratic rule I think one of the
interesting things here is that we are
largely expecting a fairly technocratic
cabinet to be announced during the
transitional period and the political
parties themselves will take their place
within the Legislative Council which
will be formed after 90 days so while
there might be some you know positioning
that happens within the next three years
I'm certain there will be within both
the military figures and the figures
within the executive it is in some part
offset by the structure of the
transitional government
the sovereign council is said to be a
test in the power sharing agreement
between the military and civilians
soudanese say if at the end of its
period the military does hand power to a
civilian government that's when they
will know that they're on the right
track to democracy
Hiba morgan al-jazeera cartoon
[Music]